[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
gründonnerstag norbert lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den sport guten morgen
sagt familie wir haben unter anderem
diese themen für sie
schlag gegen radikale chat gruppe ihre
mitglieder sollen sprengstoffanschläge
geplant haben und die entführung von
gesundheitsminister lauterbach
wer ist die neue familienministerin
die grünen-abgeordnete lisa paus soll
nachfolgerin von anne spiegel werden
und hoffen auf ein jahrhundertspiel
tausende fans von eintracht frankfurt
fiebern in barcelona dem europa league
viertelfinale entgegen
die stromversorgung lahmlegen
gesundheitsminister lauterbach entführen
und dann im allgemeinen chaos die macht
in deutschland übernehmen das war nach
überzeugung der ermittler der plan der
gruppe einer mischung aus querdenkern
impfgegnern und so genannten reichs
bürgern die ermittler kamen ihr zuvor
mit bundesweiten durchsuchungen und vier
festnahmen anna duda und dorothee schmid
haben details
anschläge auf umspannwerke und ein
mehrtägiger stromausfall das sollte zu
bürgerkriegsähnlichen zuständen und
letztlich zum sturz der regierung führen
mitglieder der telegram gruppe vereinte
patrioten sondern so genannten tags
vorbereitet haben auch eine entführung
zählte zu ihrem aktionsplan sie trug den
titel klabautermann
hier hinter verbarg sich der plan den
bundesminister der gesundheit professor
dr lauterbach zu entführen und dessen
personenschutz praktisch als
kollateralschaden auszuschalten
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach hatte bereits in der
vergangenheit von drohungen gegen ihn
berichtet er sei bestürzt über die
aktuellen ermittlungen hier geht es also
um kräfte die eine also absicht haben
auch den staats- und die demokratie zu
destabilisieren nutzen offenbar die
korona proteste seine kleinen minderheit
in der gesellschaft aber hoch gefährlich
bei razzien stellten die ermittler innen
waffen munition bargeld und zahlreiche
goldbach sicher vier personen nahmen sie
fest in den chat gruppen wurde zum
umsturz aufgerufen seit vorbereitet es
kann jetzt jeden tag losgehen nennt es
marschbefehl das system muss weg für
unsere kinder für unsere zukunft wir
haben es mit einer schwerwiegenden
terroristischen anschlags planungen zu
tun wir müssen sagen dass die
entführungs pläne und auch umsturzpläne
eine neue qualität sind insgesamt wird
gegen zwölf personen ermittelt
sie werden der korona protestszene und
der reichs bürgerbewegung zugeordnet
die neue bundesfamilienministerin steht
fest die bisherige anne spiegel war ja
am montag wegen ihres verhaltens während
der flutkatastrophe
zurückgetreten ihr folgt lisa paus
ebenfalls eine grüne ebenfalls aus dem
linken parteiflügel die
53-jährige ist volkswirtin seit 2009 im
bundestag und mutter eines sohnes ines
trams stellt sie vor
eine überraschung sie soll
familienministerin werden lisa paus
volkswirtin finanzpolitikerin
bundestagsabgeordnete und politisch klar
links dass die balance zwischen rechtem
und linkem parteiflügel das
entscheidende kriterium war weisen die
vorsitzenden allerdings zurück lisa paus
ist dafür genau die richtige person mit
ihrem sachverstand mit ihren
ökonomischen kenntnissen mit ihrer
erfahrung und mit ihrer leidenschaft für
soziale themen sie brenne für soziale
gerechtigkeit sagt paus erste priorität
eine kindergrundsicherung wir war
kinderarmut immer ein riesen dorn im
auge und jetzt werden wir die
kindergrundsicherung
endlich so gestalten dass sie wirksam
vor armut schützt und ankommt seit 2009
ist die heute 53-jährige im bundestag
mit dem thema familie hatte sie bislang
nur im rahmen von finanzpolitik zu tun
einen namen machte sie sich mit ihrem
kampf gegen steuerbetrug
wirecard u ausschuss ging sie olaf
scholz als früheren finanzminister
scharf an nun will sie in sein kabinett
gerade in diesen zeiten
bräuchte deutschland eine
führungspersönlichkeit die eben auch
fehler einräumen kann und ich glaube
dass es etwas was olaf scholz nicht
gegeben ist die finanzexperten haus muss
nun zeigen dass sie ihr wissen von
finanzen und wirtschaft in der
familienpolitik anwenden kann
mangelnde führung das wird dem
bundeskanzler vorgeworfen und zwar nicht
mehr nur aus der opposition sondern auch
aus seiner koalition vor allem wird
scholz aufgefordert der lieferung von
schweren waffen in die ukraine
zuzustimmen die außenministerin ist
dafür das problem sei im kanzleramt sagt
anton hofreiter gerade aus der ukraine
zurückgekehrte grüner parlamentarier
das buch hat mir die flensburger
fahrzeugbau gmbh hat sich spezialisiert
auf die umrüstung und reparatur von
schwerem gerät auf ihrem hof stehen
unter anderem 100 leopard 1 panzer und
60 panzer moerser all das was die
ukraine gut gebrauchen könnte wenn denn
die bundesregierung entscheiden würde
einer solchen wirklich schlimmen krisen
situation wäre es gut der kanzler macht
von der von seinem recht gebrauch die
leitlinie vorzugeben das vermisse ich
und das bedauere ich auch sehr weil die
ukraine kann nicht warten bis
deutschland sich sortiert hat die kritik
an bundeskanzler wächst und sie kommt
von abgeordneten die sich selber vor ort
in der ukraine einen eindruck über die
situation gemacht haben von abgeordneten
aus reihen der koalition
sie haben im grunde große hoffnungen auf
deutschland würden sich wünschen dass
unser kanzler endlich die verantwortung
übernimmt den kanzler eines so großen
und wichtigen landes in europa vor allem
die spd ist gespalten vom mächtigen
fraktionsvorsitzenden mützenich
jedenfalls kommen deutlich vernehmbare
bedenken sich vor ort ein bild zu machen
kann richtig sein unter diesem eindruck
allerdings bisher beispiellose
entscheidungen zu fordern ohne sie
selbst verantworten zu müssen ist falsch
zumal diese weitgehende konsequenzen für
die sicherheit unseres landes und der
nato haben könnten die flensburger firma
wurde anfang märz vom
verteidigungsministerium aufgefordert
ein aufstellung zu machen was sie
liefern könnte seitdem haben sie aus
berlin nichts mehr gehört
gunther love energy in berlin wie
gefährlich ist diese führungsdiskussion
für den kanzler und für die koalition ja
für den kanzler kann das natürlich zum
image problem werden wenn der eindruck
entsteht dass er sich an so
grundsätzlichen debatten nicht
öffentlich beteiligt und schon gar nicht
öffentlich den ton angibt und es ist ja
auch bemerkenswert dass die kritischen
stimmen stimmen an diesem führungsstil
mittlerweile aus allen drei
koalitionsparteien kommen die stimmen
die wir da gehört haben sind auch nicht
irgendwer das sind 3
ausschussvorsitzende im bundestag also
keine politischen leichtgewichte aber
man muss auch dazu sagen innerhalb der
koalition haben sich jetzt schon andere
stimmen zu wort gemeldet die noch mehr
politisches gewicht auf die waage
bringen rolf mützenich den
fraktionsvorsitzenden im bundestag der
spd haben wir gerade eben schon gehört
der hat einen regelrechten schriftlichen
anpfiff erteilt zu diesen forderungen
richtung führungsstil und es hat sich
auch geäußert der parteivorsitzende der
grünen omid nouripour der hat in
richtung anton hofreiter gesagt also
diese kritik am führungsstil das sei
nicht die position von bündnis 90 die
grünen offensichtlich hat er das
führungspersonal der koalitionsparteien
kein interesse daran das ganze zu
koalitionskrach werden zu lassen und
olaf scholz hat übrigens gestern im
inforadio vom rbb schon gesagt zu seinem
führungsstil gerade weil er nicht das
mache was andere von ihm verlangen führe
er doch ist es also nicht zu erwarten
dass er diesen stil jetzt so bald ändern
wird
dankeschön nach berlin für diese
einschätzung schlag und alaba nati
jetzt zum krieg in der ukraine
da gab es für russland einen rückschlag
die moskwa das flaggschiff der
russischen schwarzmeerflotte ist schwer
beschädigt durch einen brand sagen die
russen durch unsere raketen heißt es aus
kiel das ganze geschah vor mario pohl
wie vielerorts im osten bereiten sie
sich hier auf eine russische
großoffensive vor antwort kuschelten
sie leisten weiter widerstand
ukrainische soldaten in mario pohl sie
bereiten sich vor auf die wohl
entscheidende schlacht und verteidigen
nur noch trümmer die strategisch
wichtige hafenstadt ist fast komplett
zerstört
ein ähnliches szenario befürchten
militärexperten für weitere städte im
osten des landes hier wird eine
grossoffensive der russischen armee
erwartet diese könnte von lithium
staaten erste ziele wären dann wohl die
städte zloty anzug und krawatte die
ukraine geht davon aus dass die
russischen luftangriffe in den kommenden
tagen weiter zunehmen werden um die
großoffensive im osten vorzubereiten
das eigentliche ziel war tatsächlich die
ukraine unter kontrolle zu nehmen sie
politisch zu kontrollieren und letztlich
in zukunft keine unabhängige souveräne
ukraine mehr zu haben sondern letztlich
ein vasallenstaat von russland und
dieses ziel ist jetzt ein bisschen
zurückgestellt worden russland gibt vor
sich auf dem jaunpass zu konzentrieren
aber wir müssen leider davon ausgehen
dass dieses langfristige ziel nur
zurückgestellt worden ist die ukraine
behauptet sie habe der russischen marine
heute einen schweren verlust beigefügt
und den raketenkreuzer moskwa versenkt
dieses satellitenbild zeigt den stolz
der schwarzmeerflotte vor vier tagen in
gewässern vor der krim
der kreuzer moskwa wurde von einer chefs
ab der rakete getroffen dann explodierte
munition an bord und das schiff begann
zu sinken
die russische darstellung klingt etwas
anders man habe das feuer gelöscht und
das schiff in einen hafen gebracht sagt
moskau ohne dabei bilder zu liefern die
das belegen
fragen nach ihr von tim kröger wann
erwartet man in der ukraine die
russische offensive
also nach ukrainischen angaben sind die
vorbereitung für eine solche offensive
weitgehend abgeschlossen beispielsweise
die truppenbewegungen oder auch die
verlegung von material also ein solcher
angriff könnte laut ukrainischer seite
unmittelbar bevorstehen prenzel lenski
spricht davon dass die russische seite
in dieser region zehntausende von
soldaten zusammengezogen hat oder noch
dabei ist er hat seine warnung vor einer
solchen offensive in den vergangenen
tagen noch einmal massiv intensiviert
und deswegen wird jetzt auch versucht
noch einmal so viele menschen wie
möglich aus diesen potentiellen
kampfzonen herauszuholen sie also zu
evakuieren ukrainische offizielle
sprechen davon dass diese sogenannte
schlacht um den don was an dem zweiten
weltkrieg erinnern könnte ganze städte
könnten zerstört werden und die
ukrainische seite hat bereits massive
gegenwehr angekündigt dieser krieg
könnte also jetzt tatsächlich in eine
neue phase eintreten in den kommenden
tagen und wochen in eine phase die noch
einmal brutaler ist als der krieg ist
bislang ohnehin schon war
live aus kiew hinkriege vielen dank
bei zdf heute live erzählen zwei
ermittler wie sie in der ukraine beweise
für mutmaßliche kriegsverbrechen sammeln
um 19 uhr 30 in der zdf- heute- app und
auf unseren social media kanälen
7,3 prozent inflation in deutschland das
bereitet vielen sorge jetzt ist die
europäische zentralbank gefragt
schließlich soll sie für preisstabilität
sorgen durch die ezb entschied heute
erstmal nicht einzugreifen der leitzins
bleibt bei 0 prozent
die zentralbanker fürchten dass höhere
zinsen die konjunktur weiter abwürgen
könnten denn die wirtschaft stehe schon
wegen des ukraine kriegs erheblich unter
druck
umweltschützer sehen
hybridautos schon lange als mogelpackung
jetzt will das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium die
kaufprämie für alle plug-in-hybride
schon ende des jahres streichen anders
als im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart seit juli 2020 gibt es für
autos mit elektro- und verbrennungsmotor
bis zu 4500 euro allein vom staat die
prämie ist umstritten denn die hybride
verbrauchen oft mehr benzin als
angegeben und fahren nur kurze strecken
elektrisch anselm stern
mehr als 1,1 millionen elektroautos sind
derzeit unterwegs auf deutschen straßen
etwa die hälfte davon so genannte plug
in hybride also die kombination aus
elektro- und
verbrennungsmotor will der
wirtschaftsminister streichen früher als
geplant und anders als im
koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben wer finanzielle grund
ist dass wir einen enormen hochlaufen
immobilität haben und nur begrenzte
haushaltsmitteln ich glaube dass die
käufer von plug in hybriden jetzt
sowieso kaufen würden und dann setzen
wir das geld lieber da ein wo noch nicht
das sowieso kaufen stattfindet das wäre
die überlegung die hinter den hinter der
aktion steht sagt robert habeck und
bekommt gegenwind aus der eigenen
koalition aus fdp und spd und aus der
auto-branche die förderung für
plug-in-hybride sind ist ganz zentral
für den einstieg wieder verbrauchern
verbraucher in die e-mobilität hier gibt
es keine reichweiten angst bei
langstreckenfahrten völlig anders sehen
dass umweltverbände überfällig sei der
ausstieg aus der hybrid förderung nach
in hybriden verbinden die nachteile von
verbrennungsmotor und elektroantrieb
es ist in der regel ein schwacher
elektromotor eine kleine batterie und
ein sehr effizienter verbrenner das
führt dazu dass man wenn überhaupt nur
kurze strecken elektrisch fahren kann
das heißt diese fahrzeuge sind wahre
klimakiller
der klima minister plant noch weitere
änderungen die fördergelder vom bund für
reine elektroautos sollen sinken auf
4000 euro im kommenden und 3000 euro in
den folgejahren
schauen wir auf die aktuelle corona lage
in deutschland die sieben tage incident
senkt weiter auf 1015 7 dem robert koch
institut wurden 165
1368 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages gemeldet und 36.000 weniger als
vor einer woche 310 todesfälle kamen
dazu
größter einzelaktionär ist da schon
jetzt will tesla chef elon musk den
kurznachrichtendienst twitter ganz
kaufen für 43 milliarden dollar die
entscheidende frage ist allerdings ob
genug aktionäre ihre anteile an ihn
verkaufen der milliardär will das
unternehmen von der börse nehmen nur so
könne sich das potenzial von twitter als
plattform für weltweite rede freiheit
entfalten sagte er
in den usa sorgt wieder ein
polizeieinsatz für empörung wieder geht
es um die tötung eines jungen schwarzen
durch einen weißen polizisten die tat
ist schon einige tage her jetzt aber
wurde ein video veröffentlicht und das
zeigt wie der polizist den mann nach
einer aus dem ruder gelaufenen
verkehrskontrolle in den hinterkopf
schießt benjamin daniel berichtet
verkehrskontrolle in grand rapids
michigan die aufnahmen zeigen wie die
polizei am 14 april patrick rioja anhält
weil dessen auto wohl nicht registriert
war plötzlich beginnt der 26-jährige
kongolesische flüchtlinge wegzurennen
als der polizist einen taser einsetzen
will versucht liga in dem beamten
abzunehmen daraufhin zieht der seine
pistole und schießt ihm in den kopf
die polizei muss sich nun vor allem der
frage stellen ob der tödliche schuss
gerechtfertigt was wir untersuchen ob
diese anwendung tödlicher gewalt aus der
sicht eines vernünftigen polizisten
nötig war um zu verhindern dass der
beamte selbst verletzt oder getötet wird
nachdem vor knapp zwei jahren ein
polizist in minneapolis den schwarzen
george floyd qualvoll töteten
kommt es in den usa immer wieder zu
großen protesten gegen polizeigewalt und
systemischen rassismus jetzt rückt die
debatte also wieder in den vordergrund
und es sieht so aus als gäbe joe biden
langsam die hoffnung auf dass das gesetz
zur reformierung der polizei durch den
senat kommt so groß der widerstand der
republikaner
der präsident plant nun einen exekutiv
befehl zu den polizei praktikum wie
dieser aussehen und was er bewirken
könnte wird nun diskutiert genauso wie
mögliche konsequenzen für den polizisten
der zurzeit beurlaubt
jetzt zur fußball-europa-league und
hibbeligen frankfurt fans in drei
stunden beginnt in barcelona das
mögliche jahrhundert im hexenkessel von
camino gegen barca das
viertelfinal-rückspiel letzte woche
hatte die eintracht zu hause ein
bärenstarkes 1 1 erkämpft jetzt wollen
tausende frankfurt fans in barcelona
ihre mannschaft zum sieg tragen
fangesänge auf den ramblas insgesamt
30.000 anhänger sind ihren team in die
katalanische hauptstadt und das riesige
kam nou stadion verfolgt steht 1 1 es
ist deshalb seit wir gehen jetzt raus in
die zweite halbzeit und unser ziel ist
das spiel zu gewinnen grund für diesen
optimismus ein forscher auftritt beim 1
1 im hinspiel gegen den fünfmaligen
sieger der königsklasse was leider
jedoch schon eine tiefe krise
durchschritten zu haben ist auf dem weg
zu alter klasse für die katalanen eine
pflichtaufgabe für die eintracht eine
art finale an unterstützung von den
tribünen wird es nicht mangeln heim
atmosphäre bei einem auswärtsspiel
gestern abend feiert liverpool mit
trainer jürgen klopp das weiterkommen in
der champions league nach dem 3 2 1
-sieg in lissabon reichte den reds zu
hause ein 3 3-unentschieden gegen
benfica zweifache fc torschütze roberto
firmino seit dem champions league gewinn
2009 10 steht liverpool erstmals wieder
im halbfinale und trifft auf bayern
bezwinger villarreal ja und auch mancity
und trainer pep guardiola stehen im
halbfinale in reicht da 1 0 zu 0 gegen
atletico madrid ein alles andere als
schönes spiel mit unschönen schluss
ziehen atletico philipp er flog nach
einem fordern fünf hunden mit gelb-rot
vom platz danach rangeleien zwischen den
spielern auf dem feld ja und danach nach
spielende auch im kabinengang die
polizei musste einschreiten
die deutschen handballer sind mit einem
erfolgserlebnis in die play offs um die
wm-qualifikation gestartet im hinspiel
gegen außenseiter färöer siegte das dhb
team von trainer gislason gestern abend
in kiel mit 34 zu
26 alexanders wäre hat das viertelfinale
beim atp tennisturnier in monte carlo
erreicht der 24 jährige hamburger unten
im bild setzte sich trotz
break-rückstand in beiden sätzen
insgesamt souverän mit 6 2 7 5 gegen den
spanier pablo karin robuster durch im
viertelfinale warten der russe andrey
orlov oder der südtiroler ja nix sinn
mehr dazu dann morgen dankeschön damit
das osterwetter wird sonnig aber nicht
ganz so warm details hat sich aus dem
tal marietta franka freut sich auch sie
um viertel vor zehn im heute-journal wir
alle danken viel interesse und wünschen
ihnen schöne feiertage bis morgen wenn
sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ruhiges wetter
gibt es über die ostertage denn dieses
hoch hier über skandinavien rutscht
langsam nach deutschland das wetter ist
zweigeteilt nach westen hin ist es
deutlich wärmer kommt die wärme aus dem
süden dafür im osten deutlich kühler die
kälte aus dem norden ja und in der nacht
gibt es einzelne schauer nach osten hin
dafür mehr schauer im süden es lockert
auf im westen bei vier bis zehn grad und
morgen daten ganz im osten relativ dicht
bewölkt mit etwas nieselregen lässt aber
nach an den alpen gibt es schauer das
wird auch weniger sonst zeigt sich immer
häufiger von westen her die sonne bei
höchsten temperaturen von acht bis 13
grad in der nordosthälfte 13 bis 21 grad
in der südwesthälfte die nächsten tage
sind ruhig sonnig und relativ warmen bei
neun bis 18 grad wobei es im osten
kühler ist als im westen ein schöner
abend